I've got a question for you.
What would happen if Ronald Reagan came
back to life and met Donald Trump in the
oval office?
Do you think they'd become friends?
Do you think that shake hands and find
common grounds with similar values and
political beliefs?
Of course,
both are considered diehard
conservatives both aren't considered a
boogie man for liberals and both had a
career in show business,
but in fact,
this is where the similarities.
Ronald Reagan's job as president was to
find the worst recession since the great
depression and to do so.
He promised the Reagan Revolution,
the so called revolution,
focusing on reducing government spending
taxes as well as regulation
government,
not government.
President Reagan likes the free markets
and believe that capitalism would solve
the nation's problems.
They also like to portray himself as a
humble paternal figure.
In other words,
he prided himself on being a man of high
moral values
would be unmistakable.
Open this gate,
trump however,
is a totally different animal.
He shows off his fortune,
his former model trophy wife,
and he is so obviously the opposite of a
paternal figure.
He's more like that weird uncle living
like a bachelor regardless of his age
and guessing,
embarrassingly drunk during family
reunions.
Wow.
On the policy side,
trump is seldom friendly toward the free
market and smaller government.
He loves debt.
The idea of trade wars and his
protectionist policy have taken care of.
America seems to be at odds with the
gips tendency to be in favor,
at least in theory of the free market.
As you can probably see,
there is a clash that runs deep in the
soul of the Republican Party,
or at least this is how it looks from an
outside perspective.
On the one hand,
there's this,
the good old party,
but loves America.
Small government,
low taxes and conservative values,
and then there is this other Republican
party that loves trophy wives,
big beautiful walls and terrorists and
who's winning?
Well,
you guessed it.
There was a wave of Republicans leaving
Congress among all of these differences
in values and policy.
The new cycle has been completely taken
over by a new wave of Republicans and
she was the most important of them all.
Well,
I would actually be pulled up Ryan,
the speaker of the House and the
Republicans,
golden boy for years for Ron,
the champion of fiscal rectitude and
smaller government,
and now he's announced that he's not
going to run for reelection,
and as you can imagine,
he's not the only one.
Many republicans might be living,
but there are always new elections and
therefore new candidates,
but also ones with questionable
characters.
Take for example,
the Alabama special elections held back
in December of 2017,
back candidate Roy Moore was buried
under tons of allegations of sexual
abuse of minors.
For these scandals,
Republicans lost the seat in Alabama for
the first time in decades,
but the biggest surprise is that a
republican president supported and
alleged sexual predator.
Could you imagine something like this
just five years ago as you could expect,
this Alabama scandal appeared on all the
national newspapers and hit the White
House,
and now you might wonder,
well,
what did Donald trump do to solve this
pr crisis?
Well,
they did absolutely nothing.
Nothing at all.
And this is one of the reasons why so
many Republican candidates are doing so
badly in the polls,
even in traditionally red states.
But what does this mean for the White
House?
Well,
for those who don't keep up with
American politics so much this year,
the country had legislative elections,
these other so called midterms.
This is when members of Congress and
many senators and relax it in America,
the president,
and that is the executive power is voted
in during one election,
in the legislative power during another.
This is why,
for example,
despite Obama being Democrats,
the majority of the legislative chambers
were Republican,
and if the Republicans lose too many
seats during the 2018 midterms,
trump is going to be in dire straits
anytime he wants to pass a bill.
That the real question now is,
how did the Republican Party gassier can
a political party change their ideology
this quickly?
Well,
today we're going to answer these
questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history.
Reagan revolution.
Ronald Reagan started out as a
registered Democrats and a new deal
support,
but he left the party in 1962 crossing
over to the gop stating that he didn't
leave the Democratic Party,
but it was the party that left him.
Nevertheless,
things in the gop were not ideal either.
According to Reagan,
Republicans had bought into most of the
values of the Democratic Party and
despite the passionate rhetoric,
than once some truth to that.
Have you ever heard of cultural
hegemony?
This is a concept Marxist philosophers
like to use a lot.
According to them,
the ruling class needs to create a
consensus,
a set of moral values that are shared by
the majority of the political players,
including the opposition party.
Back then idea is like the welfare state
and the need for more governmental
control of the economy that came the new
mainstream,
even the republican side,
to accept those principles if they
wanted to be considered a serious power.
This explains why both Nixon and
Eisenhower did very little when it comes
to economics and you guys did.
Reagan was not a big fan of this.
No nation in history has ever survived a
tax burden that reached a third of its
national income today.
Thirty seven cents out of every dollar
earned in this country is the tax
collectors share.
Here comes the interesting pos.
Cultural hegemony is something that
changes over time.
How well when those values are no longer
solving people's problems.
This is what happens in the 19 seventies
with the energy crisis.
America was really not in a good place
back then and this was the window of
opportunity that Ronald Reagan needed to
reinvents the Republican Party and
create the ideological platform we used
to know as conservatism.
In other words,
he took something old and made it shiny
again by more or less creating a brands
new ideology.
The question is,
well,
how do you do that?
How can you create a brand new ideology
that makes sense and lets you win
elections?
Well,
let me introduce you to the theory of
the empty signifier.
Basically,
Ronald Reagan went to all the political
groups that fell outside of the
political mainstream at the time he
spoke to the evangelical conservative.
So one,
you spoke to the military industrial
complex guys for another,
and finally he spoke to everybody who
was tired of paying so many taxes.
Then he merged all of these groups into
one common cause,
liberty and freedom.
This is what we call an empty signifier.
It's a concept so vague that everybody
can project onto the vagueness,
the meaning that they're looking for.
For a fiscal conservative,
freedom means being free from paying so
many taxes for a whole kitchen.
Conservative freedom means fighting or
authoritarian rulers.
In this present crisis,
government is not the solution to our
problem.
Government is the problem,
but think about it.
How is it possible to have people so
different from one another on the same
platform?
It's a big time contradictions.
I have someone who wants small
government and someone else who wants to
increase military spending.
Right?
Well,
if you want to create a political
identity,
you need an antagonist.
And Ronald Reagan,
he couldn't have had it easier.
Open this gate,
Mr Gorbachev,
tear down this.
Whoa.
Yup,
Yup.
He picked the evil communists.
This is why during the 1980 [inaudible]
there were so many movies where the
communists were the bad guys.
Yeah,
you have talked to us like Red Dawn,
rocky four,
and of course,
top gun.
All of these movies,
along with Reagan's speeches,
helps create a brand new cultural,
hegemonic,
even democratic presidents like crimson
to promise tax cuts in order to win an
election.
Yes,
but as you know,
the Soviet Union fell in the nineties.
So what happens when you lose your
antagonist?
Well,
you simply find another one like
President Reagan did two decades before
President Bush operated from a Christian
worldview that distinguishes between
good and evil.
After the tragedy of September,
the 11th presidents Bush announced that
the battle ahead would be a monumental
struggle of good versus evil.
The good will prevail,
and that's how these so called evil
became America's new enemy.
We will rally the world to this caused
by our efforts,
by our courage.
We will not tire,
we will not falter,
and we will not fail,
of course.
So I'm not saying that terrorists are
communists and all evil or that they are
just some sort of fabricated monster.
Of course not,
but they can be utilized to create a
political platform.
Every important politician,
they've done it.
Roosevelt did it,
Reagan did it,
Bush did it.
But what happens when you run out of
enemies?
What happens when the Soviet Union is no
more?
Or when bin Laden is debt?
Well,
this is the time for,
oh,
but trump revolution after the 2008
financial crisis,
the economic mainstream,
the cultural hegemony was once again a
challenge resulting in people not
trusting the economic mainstream
anymore.
The word didn't spread through
mainstream media and immediately the
question arose whether or not the lack
of coverage was because it wasn't
newsworthy or because some of the people
being protested against have the control
over the various mainstream media
outlets on September 30th.
We took a trip into the city to see what
it wasn't being talked about.
When people lose faith in something
that's usually leaves a void that needs
to be filled by a new kind of discourse
and here sweeps in Canada.
Did Donald J dot trump with his
inflammatory speeches during campaign
rallies all his personal scandals and is
scorching and polarizing public
statements once again,
a new presidential candidate managed to
align himself with an astounding variety
of political and religious groups that
felt misrepresented by the mainstream.
In fact,
80 percent of evangelical Christians
voted for trump much more than any other
religious Greek evangelical Christian
values are about family and moral
integrity.
So why is a guy like trump with all his
divorces and sexual scandals not
perceived as immoral by them?
Well,
even in the light of the recent media
storm surrounding the alleged cash
payment,
do you silence Pornstar?
Stormy Daniels?
Seventy eight percent of evangelical
voters still support trump as army
evangelical leaders went as far as
publicly stating they have given the
president's what they called a Mulligan.
A do over.
I bought a gun,
is a golf metaphor,
which is strangely appropriate.
It's considering trumps passion for that
sport.
Yes,
evangelical conservatives gave him a
Mulligan.
They let them have a do over.
They said,
we will start fresh with you and give
you a second chance.
Tony Perkins,
speaking at CNN,
so how is this possible?
Well,
as you might've guessed,
the antagonists come into play,
so who or what is trump's political
enemy?
The first group that immediately comes
to mind is the mainstream media,
or as the American president calls them
the fake news media.
The second enemy is the so called swamp.
A term that refers to the not so clean
and not so transparent political scene
in Washington.
The third have many more enemies is you
guessed it,
immigrants,
so trump can always play the me or the
others card and it seems to work for
him.
So what do all these talking points have
in common?
Well,
that's the outright has been using them
for years.
Trump managed to appeal to evangelicals
and members of the foreign rights that
for a long time it felt misinterpreted
by the liberal and mainstream media and
trump's rhetoric on migration also
driven the support of the extreme far
right.
Sometimes the Neo Nazi rally in
Charlottesville.
It wasn't later condemned by the
president.
He went so far as to say that the were
very fine.
People on both sides
from Mexico.
Can us too bad on the trump campaign in
two moments.
Trump's rhetoric has also spawned a lot
of Republican candidates.
This are trying to appeal to the same
voters that are at the core base of the
presidents going so far as to state that
they are trumpea than trump,
but does it actually work,
but apparently it works pretty well for
those bearing the trump name.
Take,
for example,
the West Virginia Republican primary,
one of the candidates came up with an ad
that was filled to the brim with trump's
preferred phrases,
the idioms,
and yet still he came up last in the
race
swap.
Captain Mitch Mcconnell has created
millions of jobs for China people while
doing so.
Mitch has gotten rid of.
In fact,
there's China.
Family has given him tens of millions of
dollars.
Micha swamp people are now running false
negative ads against me
in order to give you a fuller accounts
of the trump presidency would kind of
need a few days.
In the meantime,
considering all this controversy well,
how other Republicans doing,
many political analysts believe that the
democratic blue wave and they crash onto
these midterm elections,
but is it only a reaction to trump
scandals or the democratic inclined
voters more energized?
Republicans are losing 2018 midterm
money wars
as reported by CNN.
The GOP is worried about these incoming
midterm elections.
In that piece,
CNN reported that senior members of the
party are wanting the younger members to
accumulate as many donations as possible
in order to be able to successfully run
campaigns in a difficult political
culture.
Suffice it to say that in the is most
competitive house races,
40 Republicans have been outraged by
that democratic challenges with our
speaker,
Paul Ryan's abrupt access to the
Republican corporate donor base was a
bit shaken,
a number of party donors and operatives
believed that the speaker's acts.
It was the final piece of evidence that
they needed to flip their attention from
the house to the Senate,
and that means empty house wallets for
House Republicans,
which will pretty much be left to fend
for themselves.
But
we need to remember that when it comes
to politics,
nothing is written in stone.
We have visual politic.
We're going to be keeping a close eye on
these upcoming midterms,
but as always,
you do need to run another.
When it comes to politics,
nothing's written in stone.
We have visual politic.
We're getting to pay special attention
to these upcoming midterms.
So now it's your turn.
All the Republicans losing their
credibility.
Do you think that they're going to lose
votes?
Is a democratic blue wave coming to the
midterms?
Well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below.
And of course,
don't forget to visit our friends from
reconsider media.com,
the podcast that provided the vocals in
this video that went on mine and of
course visit our patrion page if you
want to support this project.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next video.
Facial body.